do you remember the first person or
entity that gave you money
and it came from distant sources yes the
first cup
it was the ministry of culture of taiwan
they gave us um
hundred thousand dollars wow for
yeah four hundred thousand dollars to
make the
film what's the conversion rate sorry
what what are we talking about here
it was like town what fortunately 400
was it 400 no
wait maybe 300 000 u.s dollars
wow yeah okay yeah yeah to make the film
wow so that was the first
uh entity that
that gave us money but even then we
couldn't raise the money
but with the ministry culture of taiwan
they give you the money but you need to
make this movie within two years
if you don't make this movie within
certain period of time you lose that
money
so we needed to come up with the rest of
the budget
so so yeah so we were hustling that's
stressful
yeah stressful yeah so they have the set
aside money like
you know different programs or whatever
for
film and things like yeah the film film
tv
music different different aspects of the
culture taiwanese culture
you know it was to try to promote tony's
culture
so this movie is very taiwanese-american
it was
part of his american ident amer asian
american experience
another part is taiwanese experience the
mother character lives in taipei
right so she represents that part of the
culture
the sun represents both taiwanese and
americans so so
it makes sense for time for ministry
culture
to be advocating for this project
um and so after that city of taipei gave
us money because we're filming taipei as
well
um type taipei
every year the end of october
taipei hosts the largest gay
pride parade in asia so it's the biggest
event so
and that's in our movie so so we
promoted that
too um yeah how long have they been
doing that
oh i don't know for like 20 i don't know
like 10
15 years i'm not really sure long time
for a long time
does it coincide with the pride that's
here in the u.s no uh
taipei pride is the end of october oh i
see okay
okay and june is cheap yeah here okay
it's coming up coming out next week yeah
in west hollywood
i'll be marching with the taiwan
ministry of culture what was the process
like to submit the film like are you
submitting the screenplay
they're reviewing it so you collaborate
with
a production company in taiwan and then
they will submit your project on your
behalf
um so yeah so you submit a screenplay it
needs to be translated in
into chinese um and then you went
through
a elimination you know process and they
you know interview like maybe i don't
know
10 15 i don't know how many projects you
interview and then you go and
present your project to a panel of
judges
and then they if they like a project if
if
aspects of your project sort of
uh have share vision
with what they're looking for then you
get it then you get the money so
yeah yeah that's that's quite a generous
amount
to to give but that being said it wasn't
enough
to get you up and running you you knew
that that two years you had to
there was a fire under you to keep going
yeah and
it was really really hard and we really
and for a year
we we wasted a year i mean it's not a
waste you learn from the experience
this is something might be interesting
for your viewers you're making a small
independent film that's under 2 million
for example what we were trying to do we
were trying to like
attach a name actor for our for one of
his supporting roles in the film
we went through the entire year we hired
a captain director
we pitched it to known hollywood actors
for the part
we went nowhere for a year so
after a year of getting nowhere
um we decided you know what this is not
going anywhere we could be we could be
doing this for 10 years and nothing
would
happen so we decided to cast someone
that's not
known for the supporting character and
we were able to make the film like that
so the advice
to filmmakers if your budget is
low indie films don't waste your time
trying to get this like a-list actor or
whatever just do the best you can
within the budget otherwise you'll be
wasting your time for a long
long long long long time so what was the
so you have this casting director
they're submitting to people's you know
agents or whatever
what what amount of time are you waiting
to hear back so like for example you
submit you through this
through casting director council
director will submit the script to
the agent of this actor and we wouldn't
hear from them for a month
and then they once you submitted the
script to that actor
you're not going to submit to it you
can't submit to multiple actors so you
have to wait for a month
and they don't even read it they don't
get back to you
for a month and and and if they get back
to you
pass right right so you have to do the
process again for another month
if they respond you know pass
and it's we go through the entire year
and by the time a year passes and you're
like oh my god i'm so frustrated
oh my god maybe your script sucks maybe
it's bad whatever
so these are the things like that
distractions
um that keeps you focused on making the
project
um so yeah don't do what i did
so then because you will you knew you
had like you know this clock was ticking
you had this
nice sum of money that would definitely
really help the production that's got to
be very stressful
yeah to know it could go away yeah so so
then once you found
the the name that you wanted for the
supporting character
then how did you get the other producers
on board
or you no you just had the city of
taipei and then
taiwanese uh ministry of culture well
all those entities are
financiers in a way they give us the
money
the producer came on board
and then we cast it and then we did the
casting
oh okay so the producer um that came on
board um the producer of crouching tiger
hidden dragon
lee kung soo he he was very open to
an actor that's not known so with his
blessing we were able to
cast the film no one's known in a movie
except for the mother character who's
meryl streep of asia she's
so famous in asia but there's no one
hollywood name you know so
so yeah so we made the movie although
if if we kept trying to get
a hollywood a-list name after we
i we will still be trying now wow
you